it is a disaster here we're actually
across from the convention center in
downtown houston which has been set up
as a shelter
for storm victims houston mayor
sylvester turner said minutes ago that
about
5600 people are now in emergency
shelters and that number will rise fema
says 450 000 people are potential
disaster victims and fema estimates more
than 30 000 people will need temporary
shelter at the place like behind me
there's 270 thousand families who are
without power and jamie yukas is with
one rescue crew searching for victims in
houston jamie good morning
good morning norah i can tell you right
now we're on an airboat and what's
happening right now is we're in a gated
community in southwest houston in a
place called sugarland and the problem
that's happening is that there's the
oyster bay area that's filtering into a
lake here in this neighborhood called
pumpkin lake and you can see now
virtually everything is under water
because those two bodies of water have
poured into here and there's nowhere for
all the rain that we've been talking
about to go now i'm with the sheriff of
this area and the water has just
continued to rise what we're doing right
now is we're going through the
neighborhood to make sure and see who
needs to be rescued who wants to still
stay put and what i've been surprised
about sheriff troy nels with me now what
i've been surprised about is that
there's a number of people who want to
be rescued but they're still not ready
even though the neighborhood looks like
this understood maybe they felt nobody
was able to get back in here obviously
there's no uh wheeled vehicle getting
back and forth out of this neighborhood
it must be a boat so we're driving
through this community here in this
airboat here seeing if people would like
to get out we're asking them to leave
you're asking them at this point to
leave yes there's no reason to be in
your house anymore i mean we've got a
couple more days of this the water's up
to the front of their uh their front
door so
i see no need or no reason no logic to
want to stay here right now and at this
point this area was not under a
mandatory evacuation when hurricane
harvey was coming through no we have a
little oyster creek that runs through
here oyster creek eventually feeds into
the brazos river they say the brazos
river is going to get to 59 feet
last memorial day 2016 was the record 54
feet so this is going to experience much
more water than we currently see right
now and you told me if people are inside
their homes they may have to be here for
a week and a lot of people just don't
have food and water for that period of
time i'm not telling them they have to
leave but when i'm telling them they
could be here for several days
and that could be a problem now we have
been looking right now i can see there's
a man standing outside his home he's
recording kind of what's happening are
you staying put sir he's staying put so
there's a number of people who are
riding out uh this particular storm you
can see the sheriff though going over to
this family right now to see if they
want to be rescued and this has been the
situation for us throughout much of the
morning we've witnessed four or five
different families say i want to get out
and i want to get out right now
including one family of eight that had
two children including a baby and a dog
who had to leave their home at the last
minute nora
jamie a lot of people trying to get out
of their homes today thank you so much